you say the quality of your life is a
direct correlation to your muscle Health
why because muscle is the organ of
longevity and your capacity to show up
and execute anything and everything that
you want in your life depends on your
strength and in order to build physical
strength it requires mental strength it
requires fortitude it requires
resiliency and right now we have this
conversation about longevity and health
span what does that actually mean that
actually relates to the tangible
plasticity of skeletal muscle and by the
way you know we were kind of joking
around podcasters in Austin but when you
think about skeletal muscle you often
think about broscience you think about
the big dudes skeletal muscle is so much
more than that and in fact the health of
your life depends on the health and the
quality of your tissue interesting
obviously the byproducts of building
muscle uh discipline resilience being
able to overcome hard things consistency
motivation so on and so forth somebody
quite easily could say well I get that
with distance running I get that with
rowing I get that with doing yoga what
is it specifically about muscle building
that is important for
longevity well when you think about
skeletal muscle there's there's a couple
things that you have to think about
skeletal muscle is the primary site for
glucose disposal right now if you look
at the CDC and they'll give you a list
of causes of death it'll put uh
cardiovascular disease it'll put cancer
it'll put diabetes it won't put obesity
on there and it won't put lack of
skeletal muscle it'll also have
Alzheimer's what you'll see is that
these diseases at the root all have its
place in skeletal muscle first and
foremost so if you care about any of the
top eight or nine causes of death you
have to care about skeleton muscle now
what's what's the next level to that
could endurance running be great yes
it's amazing is Yoga great sure
absolutely you have to also train for
strength and train for Life having
skeletal muscle is like your body armor
we've all had friends family members
that have gotten sick if they were
amazing in endurance training but had
very little skeletal muscle what is
going to protect them in those moments
of catabolic crisis so we don't age
Chris we don't age linearly it's not as
if that this slow decline what happens
is there's an insult and then there is a
rapid Decline and then depending on your
capacity to step back up is based on
your ability to have healthy skeletal
muscle in part it's called catabolic
crisis what what do you mean when you
say insult or catabolic crisis so for
example if you fall and you're injured
or you get sick and you have pneumonia
for a week when you're younger your
ability to get back up to Baseline to be
more physically active is more flexible
as you age we've all seen it as you age
an individual um grandmother breaks a
hip she'll never be able to rise back up
to her Baseline level of functioning
potentially she could but as she gets
older the ability to return to a more
youthful Baseline decreases and that has
to be trained for you have to be able to
be strong you do have to be able to
build muscle and skeletal muscle is
interesting the skeletal muscle MUSC is
a nutrient sensing organ skeletal muscle
is an organ system it's a nutrient
sensing organ system that senses the
quality of the diet and specifically
these amino acids specifically Lucine
I'm sure we'll get into it but that
efficiency goes down as we age if you
train and eat and do the things you did
in your youth you not evolving um you
know there's you know mental Evolution
there's all kind of more esoteric
Evolution but you also have to keep up
with an evolving physiological process
and a biological process and that's
where focusing on hypertrophy and
strength obviously they're not the same
but focusing on skeletal muscle as a
tissue as it relates to medicine is
Paramount so I understand definitely
from the literal physical body armor
perspective somebody Falls if they have
more muscle that is supporting around
their joints it means that there's going
to be less atrophy it means they're
going to be able to get back to function
more quickly but you went through this
whole Litany of other things like
Alzheimer's Parkinson's
dementia you know heart disease talk to
me about the mechanism of what having
skeletal muscle is doing that helps to
mitigate the onset of that or delay what
what's skeletal muscle doing to our
health span well can I start with a just
a very short story a very short story to
bring the listener in because they're
thinking dude Chris is jacked he's
bringing in these tough big dudes
talking about muscle you've had myre
everyone is thinking it everyone that's
listening they can't stop thinking it
they TR they can't look at you they
can't you've had Stan eering you've had
Chris plumstead people that I just know
and love let's talk about muscle from a
different perspective and I promise I'll
make the story short I did um my
fellowship in nutritional sciences and
geriatrics and I did that in uh at wasu
for those the listeners that don't know
it's a very rigorous program it's
considered the Harvard of the Midwest
it's very challenging and I actually
didn't want to do geriatric medicine the
deal was in order for me to study
nutritional sciences and obesity
medicine I had to get funded and the way
that I was going to get funded was
through geriatric
training so during the day I was working
with individuals that were over the age
of 65 and they were the majority not
healthy
um on the alzheimer's unit in nursing
homes end of Life pallative Care it gets
extremely depressing when you're seeing
30 patients a day talking to their
families about what their wishes are Etc
right and I think any doctor would
attest to that and then early mornings
you know when you're a fellow you have
very minimal quality of life especially
if you're a combined research fellow
waking up at 4 in the morning doing fat
and muscle biopsies and then in the
evening doing cognitive testing um
and I fell in love with one of the
participants and she was in her mid-50s
a mom of three and she was like so many
women that we know she always put
herself last she yo-yo dieted Weight
Watchers you name it she did everything
every single thing that we told her was
the right thing to do I imaged her brain
and her brain looked like the beginning
of an Alzheimer's
brain
and I realized that we failed her we
failed her the medical community had
failed her and I couldn't stop thinking
about it I needed to find a solution
that how was it that we were giving this
information um move more eat less follow
a food guide pyramid how are we not
getting this together what is happening
and then I started thinking as I'm
rounding in the nursing homes and I'm
seeing these patients and I'm seeing
them die and I'm watching kind of this
spectrum and I realized that it wasn't
that they were
overfat it was that they were under
muscled and that we have been trying to
fix the wrong Paradigm for the last 50
years and that the diseases and the
disease process that I was seeing and
we'll call her Betty was beginning in
her 30s like this began in her 30s and
this constant iteration and plethora of
information of focusing on what we have
to lose the quote obesity epidemic it's
not an obesity epidemic obesity is a
symptom of unhealthy skeletal muscle
obesity and like you mentioned
Alzheimer's the things that ride along
with it have roots in skeletal muscle
decades and decades before they become
an issue and I wanted to frame that for
you because that's what's critical to
understand we have a
whole population focused on what they
have to lose we have over 40% of the
population focus on the wrong thing we
are setting themselves that we are
setting them up for failure it's not an
obesity problem skeletal muscle is at
the core skeletal muscle skeletal muscle
insulin resistance there's some great
data um that one of the Hallmark studies
came out of Yale looking at 18-year-old
in college students that had no outward
signs of insulin resistance when they
became
sedentary pathology in skeletal muscle
started skeletal muscle is a primary
site for glucose disposal you know I
know that we've got a lot of mutual
friends when they're running and doing a
million miles skeletal muscle where
they're going to put their carbohydrates
is it's going to be stor as glycogen and
skeletal muscle people talk all about
carbohydrates nutrition is more electric
than probably religion skeletal muscle
is again the site of carbohydrate
disposal it is a site of fatty acid
oxidation we have 40 million people on
statins why not focus on the health of
skeletal muscle
prior we have um
of mitochondrial density in skeletal
muscle when skeletal muscle contracts it
releases myocin skeletal muscle is an
endocrine organ system interfaces with
brain for
neurogenesis you name it skeletal muscle
interfaces with the immune system and
and in multiple different ways it
releases interlukin 6 which is a myokine
the most famous one also releases
glutamine Contracting skeletal muscle
releases glutamine which directly feed
lymphocytes cells of the immune
system so if we are truly going to
change the Paradigm of Health we have to
frame the question correctly so that's
what skeletal muscle does and then of
course you look good naked and all the
other dating things that you may be
talking about there's all that other
stuff okay so there's look good
naked and then be strong and capable and
age well and be able to do the things
that you love so that you can show up
for the life that you've created in a
strong and capable way I often think
about my kind of Heritage training in my
20s and how I was 18 years old and I got
to the Center for sporting Excellence at
Newcastle University and I
was I think I was about 63 kilos which
is just not heavy I'm built to be very
small I'm built to be very very slight
and um I remember the first day it was
about 2 and a half years later I hit 70
kilos and I was like I am massive uh and
now I walk around at like a a portly 88
and I'm like God I wish I was 70 it was
so much easier to move around when I was
70 but I think about the fact that the
reason I started training is because I
wanted to be more attractive to girls
and I wanted to feel more powerful I
wanted to look and feel like a man right
even though you've still got the body if
you're an like ectomorphy kind of guy 18
years old you've still got the body of a
teenager you don't have the body of a
man and I didn't want that I want it to
change but it's kind of like um come for
the gain stay for the longevity right
that you arrive because of how it makes
you look and how other people respond to
you and the progress that you see in the
mirror but it seems as you're saying
here that Downstream from this the
benefits that you get from a
physiological perspective from a
longevity Health span perspective are
pretty drastic so if it's the case right
if there is an unseen mechanism which we
could be using a pathway physiologically
which would mitigate people from getting
ill and help us to defeat disease
disease more effectively and blow off
glucose and and improve insulin
sensitivity all of the things that
you've just listed why is it the case
that there is such an obsession with BMI
with losing weight with reducing fat I
spoke to Stan eing Stan eing said on
this very podcast he was talking about
the pivot between um moving from sugar
to aspartam uh aspartame on um diet
drinks and he said what people don't
consider is the sheer impact of the
weight loss itself will be so beneficial
that any increase that you are concerned
even though the concern about like
Aspartame is is like 8,000 Cokes a day
you'd have to drink in order for you to
hit some sort of threshold that would be
dangerous even him the strongest
bodybuilder on the planet was telling me
weight loss is very important so talk to
me about this relationship between
obesity like being overfat and underused
as you call it like what what's this
relationship where is it important and
what what kind of gets missed off in
this conversation
well first thing I think it's really
important to recognize is that we don't
directly measure skeletal muscle mass
routinely again this flies in the face
of have we been asking the correct
question and in my mind the answer is no
we use dexa which is a dual x-ray we've
all heard of dexa and that actually
measures uh
bone and fat and then there's lean body
mass and lean body mass includes
everything we've been directly measuring
adapost tissue and Bone but not skeletal
muscle first and foremost we have to
recognize that when we talk about
skeletal muscle when we talk about how
much we haven't had a consistent way of
looking at it just one that it which we
will eventually so there's a something
called D3 creatine which will eventually
come out it's a tagged it's a deuterated
creatine it's tagged uh you'll take a
pill you'll be able to pee on a stick
and see how much muscle mass you have
but up until that point ctmri or not
really feasible for everybody to be
doing and especially tracking over time
so the big the big picture is we haven't
been directly measuring skeletal muscle
mass we have estimations at best
secondly we measure body fat because
that seems to be at a certain level we
know that that can cause implications
whether it's 30% or more body fat we
know that there is an increase in
inflammation potentially triglycerides
hypertension uh Etc that is important to
know but again this just goes in the way
of thinking of looking at the wait until
a problem comes and we know that this is
the
problem there is data to support that it
actually it is the loss of skeletal
muscle versus the increase in body fat
that may be more detrimental and again
um I think that we're going to start to
see an emergence of more data as we
begin to directly measure skeletal
muscle mass but you will see that the
survivability of an
individual they will have a greater
survivability the more healthy skeletal
muscle mass they have do
uh you know whatever it is 50% of
Americans are obese maybe more than 50%
of Americans are obese are overweight
presumably someone that has to carry
around that much Surplus fat yeah has to
if you were to lean them out they must
have an okay bit of muscle underneath
surely is that not the way it works um
well in the data it says that they have
more muscle and so glad you brought this
up have you ever had a riye steak many
times many times have you ever had a
filet yes okay um individuals that have
obesity not all of them but typically
what happens is you get fat infiltrated
into skeletal muscle intramyocellular
fat while an individual may have more
muscle it talks nothing about the
quality of that tissue you want your
tissue to look like a fillet and
actually when we talk about pathology of
tissue what SK Cal Muscle really
requires is flux it requires activity it
requires stimulation not just walking I
mean walking is great but people are
saying well just walk you'll do that
it's not frankly enough um but it's that
flux that utilization of glycogen you
know fatty acids are used primarily by
skeletal muscle at rest which is
interesting the health of skeletal
muscle is determined by its activity
while an individual could be obese and
have potentially more muscle one has to
ask the question is it healthy skeletal
muscle that's interesting yeah because I
remember seeing this uh it's an
illustration of a a normal-sized person
and a really really overweight person
and it's an x-ray of the inside of them
and you see that the bones that both
people's bodies are scaffolded by are
exactly the same and yet you look at the
amount of mass that is scaffolded upon
them and you go wow that is crazy to
think think that somebody that's you
know 500b or 600b is only being held up
by the same buttresses that a person
that's 120 pounds is yeah yeah and and I
think what's so fascinating is that it
goes to the the point that this is very
plastic tissue you can change it it's
very uh pliable and you literally can
add Mass to an organ system in a healthy
way last time I checked you can't grow
your liver I'm not talking about alcohol
but by attention and awareness you can
make very specific changes that have a
measurable
outcome and 50 and by the way Chris 50%
of Americans don't
exercise yeah well give explain given
that we know however many percent of
people are overweight so on and so forth
what's the stats when you look at it
from your lens right the Bros lens what
is it what is it that people are or are
not doing when it comes to protein
intake resistance training muscle mass
grip strength ability to pick something
up is it like some ungodly percentage of
fathers can't lift a a daughter after
four years old or something yeah I mean
well I think that you're changing the
conversation because your guests are all
in order to be a guest on your show you
have to be at least 250 pounds I think
you have to at least be um so I
appreciate you having me on because I am
substantially less no it's the deadlift
it's the deadlift numbers you've got it
wrong it was deadlift 250 pounds not
B250 pounds okay perfect perfect um so
50% of Americans don't exercise you know
I'm not exactly sure why but the reality
is 100% of people eat if I were to say
which is going to have a bigger impact
on skeletal muscle Health it would be
training the influence of exercise and
its effect on all of the homeostatic
mechanisms in the body is profound it
influences every organ
system
however you could go your whole life
without exercising we're not saying that
that's healthy but you essentially could
100% of people have to eat and you
really must begin to pay attention to
this especially as you age and listen
the human body is totally flexible you
talk to Stan he'll eat a certain way you
talk to Chris they'll eat a certain way
the human body is amazing the question
becomes what is the ultimate outcome
that you're looking for and from my
perspective my perspective of muscle
Centric medicine skeletal muscle is the
Pinnacle of health and wellbeing muscle
Centric medicine I love that yeah so
that I poined that in
2015 and began to develop it and that's
something that we teach to other
providers very cool what was that thing
I think I read in your book something
about the relationship between a
mother's Fitness and the health of her
children yes yes ladies
train women need to train and you need
to also continue your activity while
pregnant you're not just departing and
deploying behaviors but there is some
epigenetic change the healthier and more
fit the mother is the better their
offspring will
be wow yeah what um what's the 30,000
foot view of uh training while
pregnant well first of all they say
continue to do what you do there's very
little data in literature
on training while pregnant I can tell
you what I did and I can tell you what I
tell my patients to do throughout my
pregnancy I swung kettle bells I lifted
heavy things I wasn't trying to do a one
rep max but I was incredibly active by
the way I also had hyperemesis gravitum
do you know what that is that sounds
like some Egyptian pharaoh
no something that you will never
experience and thank goodness it's
basically where you're throwing up all
day long I mean it is impressive it is
aggressive it is a something that they
don't sell you on pregnancy in the
beginning but number one you have to
understand that you're going to feel bad
so you might as well train anyway I felt
terrible I would swing CLE Bell throw up
swing CLE Bell throw up I mean it was a
sight to see man when I went into the
gym instead of having a water bottle I
had like a a
bark it was the worst yeah uh I think
they lost a lot of gym memberships that
I bet they did Doctor Over The Far Side
hurling everywhere so is there anything
are there any movements uh in density
levels that you would say you know
there's a girl that's listening or a guy
that's having a kid with her it's like
darling don't do what like don't try and
pull Sumo I don't know like is there
something that you would try and avoid
people from doing lot of burpees maybe I
don't know yeah I mean it depends right
so they'll they'll say that um activity
and walking and moving and lifting will
actually can induce labor later on again
obviously people have to figure out how
it's going with their pregnancy and what
their individual provider recommends but
listen giving birth is is like a sport
so doing squats doing those things it's
very difficult to deadlift uh pregnant
and swing kettle bells but you should be
able to carry you should be able to move
um and again it just depends on the
individual but my best advice is be fit
going into pregnancy and continue it is
there anything that you've looked at to
do with Dad fertility let's say that
there's a a guy and a girl who want to
get pregnant a bunch of my friends have
had
what do they call it conception moons
which is kind of like a baby moon but
it's before it's like for like we're
going to go one of one of them was
really really Keen to give his daughter
a French name so went to Bordeaux in an
attempt to conceive didn't happen I'm
pretty sure it happened when they were
on in Nashville or something on the way
back airport call a k call a Kid Rock um
so what about for dads you know I I've
heard a lot of my friends they'll go
like um dialing in the diet adjusting
these sorts of things is there anything
that you've seen for improving fertility
improving the quality of of sperm for
men yeah certainly diet plays a role
diet plays a role in fertility and these
this is also multifactorial it's not one
thing you can't just have a good diet
and all of a sudden your um you don't
even know your your children's names
like that is not happening but I would
say that the obvious would be have a
good diet have foods that are rich in
zinc and proteins the other thing that I
would say is we do know that the better
body composition an individual has the
better their sperm potentially the
health of their sperm is resistance
training is plays a role in that um the
other aspect that I will say because I'm
a physician is Clomid or en chopine I
don't know if you've heard of that so
selective estrogen receptor modulator
very safe been it's been used for quite
some time it's typically used in women
but we use it a lot for men um and it's
it can help improve sperm volume how
long can guys run and Chine for before
you get before you would start to be
like it's time time to back it off now
mate you could the way that there's
there's multiple ways in which uh you
could run it but we run it for we'll run
it for 25 days on and five days off and
we could run it for every day um so my
husband actually I don't know if you no
this but my husband was a seal for 10
years and now is a Urology resident so
he works at Baylor and in neurology
which is where Men's Health was born so
lip Schultz have you heard of lip
Schultz no what you got to get him on or
mohead Cara these guys are major in
andrology these were the guys that
created you know where we talk about trt
these are the guys that created this
medical practice and um I I could say
really an appropriate joke what I'm want
n okay right so yeah in your opinion is
exercise more more important than
nutrition yeah wow I mean do I have to
pick
one you got to
prioritize 100% of people eat so get
that
right yeah it's interesting to me to
think about this pivot now from what has
been quite an obsessive diet culture
for 40 years 30 years something like at
least at least yep at least and now
thinking well what are the reasons why
what are the reasons why the diet
culture is so much more fervent and and
religious as you mentioned compared with
training culture like the 5x5 and the
531 and the gvt and the push pull legs
and the five-day split guys aren't
they're all friends jeweling it out on
the internet the only people that they
all hate together are crossfitters right
so that's fine but it it's very
interesting to me and I wonder whether
this will become a Battleground as more
people plant a flag because they're very
passionate about my training modality is
an important part of who I am as a
person and it's I think a big chunk of
the
nutrition uh argument comes from almost
like a fear of death a lot of people
that are into this are doing it because
they want to improve their health span
improve their longevity and me attacking
your approach when it comes to a
nutrition Foundation is kind of the same
as me saying you think you're going to
live a long time but you're not and I
know that you're not so it's it hits
very very deep and I don't know whether
people have that same amount of
existential attachment to their training
modality but if what you're saying here
and muscle centered medicine continues
to grow as it has been it's going to get
to the stage where you are going to have
religious fights over what split should
we do you're absolutely Ely right and I
think that's interesting when you think
about training and you think about
nutrition part of the reason why people
again this is just my opinion are so at
odds with each other is because they are
unaware of the lens at which they're
viewing something through it's almost as
if they're ponds so if you look back at
the history let's say you look back at
the history of nutritional Sciences
which by the way isn't that old you look
back at the history and after the Great
Depression moving into World War II when
the backs the Americans at backs were
against the wall and were going to lose
a country they drafted the first million
men and the first million men were unfit
for war 38% I'm sorry 38% of the first
million drafted were unfit for war they
said things like they had flabby muscles
they had poor eyesight because of
vitamin A they didn't have any teeth
obviously because of the Great
Depression there was a lot of
undernourishment
this became a real threat this was the
first time that the US really identified
that nutrition was a real threat they
issued a series of I don't want to say
propaganda but a way of educating and
what they issued was in one hand they
said are you going to support Uncle Sam
and in order to support Uncle Sam here's
what you're going to do and what they
said was you're going to eat high
quality proteins you're going to eat
liver and eggs and beef and Dairy
because you need to have strong muscles
this is in this is in the 40s no idea
they said you're going to minimize
processed foods and you're going to eat
uh fruits and vegetables and even have
some like it was like sodium
electrolytes they I was really shocked
when I when I saw that part and then
they said are you g to help Hitler and
and they showed an individual who was
skinny and scrawny and here here is the
way you're going to help Hitler you're
going to not eat high quality protein
you're going going to eat processed
foods you're going to eat white
bread in the 40s they established these
guidelines and they started this whole
campaign about how we could be stronger
and more capable and vibrant and
courageous and that's what we
needed then obviously all these high
quality foods were shipped to overseas
to the soldiers they started to um for
need uh increase in processed foods you
have Sylvester Graham and John Kellogg
Sylvester gr was a minister I don't know
if you've heard of him but he was kind
of the move the The Godfather of this
what do you call vegan movement and he
started to talk about the idea that in
order to be a moral person you needed to
reduce any kind of animal products you
shouldn't drink you shouldn't have sex
you should eat very
plainly and he got um a
really influential
follower and that was uh Kellogg who
then made granola and a gram
cracker what's the story how much
legitimacy is there around the Kellogg
origin trying to Soy the men cook them
into low testosterone give me your put
your tin foil hat on and let's go let's
go full okay fine I mean I wasn't I
wasn't around at that time I wasn't
there but I think what happened was
there was an early recognition that high
quality foods were imperative to health
and wellness and we're going to lose the
country this became a high priority then
obviously we have a nation to feed and
ultimately a global a global industry
and a just a global feeding zone right
we have to do those
things process foods which are under two
different jurisdictions and commodities
in these Whole Foods um require money
they get money they make money Whoever
has the money controls the narrative so
whatever the agenda is Whoever has the
most fortitude behind that gets to
control the narrative and this is kind
of circling back to the question of why
is it so crazy I wake up and I choose
violence Chris I post something and I go
oh man I cannot wait just just I and I
have to do it see we talked offline
before and if you have a certain skill
set then you have a responsibility to
share that is that true I think so I've
been a physician since since 2006 I've
seen a lot of life and I've seen a lot
of death and so why I even started
talking about this is because I saw so
much misinformation and here I am as a
geriatrician at the bedside of like oh
signing this death cert certificate and
then this death certificate and all
these people are talking about how you
know going plant-based is going to save
the world and all this other BS and not
thinking about uh how that is going to
influence the midlife people and what
that end result result is going to be
what is the impact of going plant-based
on people that are no longer
23 I think that we are going to see an
epidemic of osteoporosis and sarcopenia
like we've never seen before what is
that for people that don't know uh
sarcopenia is a loss of skeletal mass
and function and osteoporosis is bone
density and could you be young and
plant-based could you get all the
protein again this is a very um just
like a very small perspective this idea
that plant and animal foods that it's
all just about protein protein we talk
about generically but Protein that's 20
different amino acids nine of which are
essential those nine essential those are
individual nutrients these things are
not interchangeable we are not just
talking about dietary protein we are
talking about food as a food Matrix and
the things that ride along with it for
example if you're eating high quality
protein you're getting creatine you're
getting carnitine you're getting torine
you're getting an Serene High B12 iron
these things are necessary for young
children and women and as you age it's
not like your appetite increases the
lower your quality of protein or the
lower your diet is in protein the higher
it needs to be animal based because
you're not just eating for dietary
protein you're eating for other
nutrients and so what do I think you
could be plant-based and healthy I think
that you can I think that the body is
very adaptable I think we're going to
start to see um ways in which maybe the
gut microbiome plays a role but do I
think it is an ideal diet for an aging
individual absolutely not I don't and
this is based experience looking at the
the way to improve your body composition
what are the principles of optimizing
body composition in your opinion well
nobody likes to hear this but you track
your money and you track your speed
right say yes Chris sometimes Monday
Wednesdays and Fridays you got to track
your food it's just a reality I know
people want to do intuitive eating I'm
sorry guys just get a sense of what
you're actually doing and it's annoying
but if you have goals and you know that
you need to hit those you have to be
able to track okay what is your I'm G to
stop you and get tactical each step of
the way what is the most seamless way
that you have found to track food
because it's not my fitness pal I will
fight you if you say so so what I do is
different than what I think is the
easiest thing right what's the easiest
thing um like chronometer just an
app what's your favorite what do you
tell your clients to use chronometer why
because it has just like nearly
everything in there all these different
nutrients again typically the the label
only has 14 different nutrients is that
is chronometer the one where you can
take a picture of your food or you can
speech it in and say like one uh slice
of toast with three eggs hardboiled blah
blah well again I haven't been using it
because I didn't I didn't tell you what
I do what do you do I haven't used it I
want to know what this this tapped into
the Matrix version is it is called pen
and paper oh God that's lame oh no are
you kidding super lame what are you
talking about you can write it and then
you can look at it I'm old school I'm
old school man I can tell yeah okay so
uh I write it down but then I know
exactly what I'm doing and also by the
way my food diversity is not huge and
you're going to be talking to our good
friend bados kolan I want you to ask him
what he had for lunch three weeks ago on
a Wednesday he'll be able to tell you is
it because it's the same thing that he
had for lunch every other day yep
consistency so once you know what you're
doing then uh like Smooth Sailing well I
mean this was what uh a really
interesting Insight from Alex hosi he
says that most people work really hard
at trying to alter their diet and alter
to their caloric intake and stuff but
really your diet isn't a diet it's
probably five meals that you've got in
the locker that you eat very very
regularly and it's a case of just
nudging these five meals right or
getting rid of one entirely okay I don't
do the bges anymore because it turns out
that I'm an addict for cheese and that
cheese is making it two 2,200
calories right it's not that complicated
but if you were to go on social media
you would spend at least six months in
paralysis true right so what doesn't get
man what doesn't get measured doesn't
get managed so you need to be measuring
the food that you're taking in at first
at first and I'm gonna walk you through
um and I actually talk about this in my
book for ever strong you know we haven't
really mentioned it but I wrote this
book for ever strong so that it could be
something applicable for everybody you
literally can read it it talks about the
history I know that you read it um and
it's you know an Evidence based it's an
evidence-based
manual and when you think about how you
put together a diet it's quite simple
what I recommend and what the data would
support is 7 grams of protein per pound
body weight or ideal body weight if you
want to go higher so simple so you're
what 88 180 call me 180 okay 180 is and
you're happy with that weight feel great
yeah I I should recm uh I need to lose a
bit of weight I actually did a dexa at
Fountain life in Dallas a few months ago
and it came back back at 19 and a half%
I was like that if I'm 19 and a half%
I'm the leanest looking I don't know
where this weight's gone it's like all
in my all in my foot or something uh and
then when I do an electrolysis I'm much
closer to kind of 13 and a half or so uh
so I don't know whether I don't know
whether the Dexter was uh having an off
day yeah clearly clearly having an off
day that's interesting and then it'll be
interesting to see as you track your
skeletal muscle but again this we we
have to understand that that is uh do we
know your optimal skeletal muscle I
would say we don't so yeah 180 so I
think I I try to hit 180 I Tred to go
for one gram per pound Great but it's
hard it's hard why is it so hard for me
to hit high volume protein you're not
hungry the body you're not hungry so
dietary protein number one I I want to
mention something that I think often
gets overlooked as we talk about quote
macronutrients is that protein need is
really the only macronutrient that
changes as you age the intake or need of
carbohydrates and fats like who cares
doesn't actually
change but the biological and
physiological processes of the body
require more protein as you age more
protein as you go through if you have a
catabolic crisis or if you're going
through cancer your or if you get burned
no other macronutrient changes in that
way so we have to get the story of
dietary protein right we just we have to
because it is the most effective
macronutrient when it comes from when it
comes to body recomposition when it
comes to when it comes to body
recomposition when it comes to
understanding that each of these amino
acids have diverse biological roles
again we are talking about dietary
protein but if we look at these other
amino acids like thine thine is
essential for mucin production in the
gut tryptophan is important and
essential for serotonin production
phenol alanine is critical for dopamine
production Lucine is critical for mour
signaling which is important for muscle
protein synthesis so we talk about
protein but what we really are talking
about are these individual nutrient
needs which by the way I think that that
is the next
iteration of the protein conversation is
really looking at these limiting amino
acids but I'm digressing so I'm going to
go Circle back to the 7 to one gram per
pound ideal body weight everybody who
does that in my opinion is going to do
better when it comes to people who say
Dr lion that sounds great but I get to
90 gram of protein a day and just sick
what do you advise to your clients or
what are your best hacks for increasing
that protein intake are there any
recipes any food types any what is it
what is it that you give to people well
the the question is why are they really
struggling to get that it is very
satiating you know it does uh influence
GP and pyy gut hormones the question is
why are they so full is it because
potentially their metabolism they've had
some kind of adaptive thermogenic
Genesis or is it that they just don't
have a protein appetite so the first
thing that we do is we get a sense of
what their total calories are that's the
first thing that you need to do you have
to know what you are ingesting again
like you said what you measure changes
tracks blah blah blah blah understanding
that hitting that first meal of the day
and hitting it early on again a lot of
people talk about fasting and pushing
that fasting window later I think that
there is something to be said for eating
after you are coming out of an overnight
fast your muscle is primed to be
stimulated whether it's an hour to two
hours after you wake up and then
stopping eating later on so you begin to
retrain your body through feeding
patterns the fastest way to increase
dietary protein would be a protein shake
whether it's a whey protein shake that's
my favorite or even a a whey concentrate
so it doesn't have to be an isolate a
concentrate concentrate has
immunoglobulins lactar alphaa albumin
other again thinking about food more
than just the macronutrients I think the
old school way and you know uh we could
teas Stan about this who's kind of
evolved more into the more nutrient
dense foods but the old school way is
just thinking about the macronutrients
the new school way is thinking about the
other low molecular weight molecules and
things like anthocyanins and and other
compounds that have metabolomic
properties Nutri other intermediate
properties one of the things that I used
to do was I got into fasting when David
Sinclair first came on the scene
probably five years ago ish I went to go
out to see him in Boston and he tells me
all of this amazing stuff and I you know
I still think there's a lot of there
there with it but I noticed that my
composition suffered I didn't I felt
soft uh I I looked soft comparatively um
and one of the other thing I've been
through every Bro Science Diet I did car
backloading then I went into carb Knight
then I did Skip loading did you ever do
skip loading this is impressive I've
never never even heard of that one right
so skip loading was go carb free
throughout the week and then on a Sunday
eat as many carbs as possible it was
advised to try and have a full box of
cereal just for breakfast and it was
like if you can get yourself to like a
kilo of carbs by the end of the day that
was considered a win um and just every
single different one what I realized was
i' kind of inculcated this um sacrifice
reward Dynamic I often cheat if I am
going to cheat on my diet I'll do it on
an evening time very early in the
morning right I think this is quite
common you know how many people are
picking up a marsar first thing in the
morning but they maybe do it on an
evening their will poow is depleted
they're in the house whatever whatever
but my sleep is really really negatively
impacted when I eat even within like two
and a half hours of going to bed which
is awful because out here in Austin
everyone wants to go for dinner at 8:00
at night I'm like right okay dude but by
the time I finished eating that's 9:
which means that I can maybe get some
good sleep by midnight and it's a
Tuesday right so yeah I I'm I'm coming
round to the idea that um still you know
have the window if you want do like a a
168 if that's what you like the sound of
or like you know even in
186 but I think that pivoting that
window a little bit earlier and then
trying to maybe cut off calories at 6
p.m. at night something like that sounds
like a sounds like a pretty good way to
start it I think it's it's a great way
to start and then understanding the next
macronutrient that I think about is well
I before I say that I number one the
data supports that the 24-hour dietary
protein intake is most important meaning
um how much protein you have during the
day right within a 24-hour
period I would say that protein
distribution matters and there is uh
kind of two schools of thought one is
that just make sure that you're getting
it all in it doesn't matter how you do
it I would say if you believ that then
you wouldn't believe any uh meal
distribution study or any study that
indicates muscle protein synthesis
happens because it happens at that first
meal for the all the majority of the
literature that I've ever seen it's
always about this first meal which in my
mind means that a meal distribution
matters it's not just about this 24-hour
period where you're just having one meal
of the day so for the listener who's
thinking gosh you know they're thinking
two things right now they're thinking
does Chris really have 19% body fat and
then the second thing that they're
thinking is well how am I actually going
to move the needle if I want to lose
weight and I would say Obviously you
figure out your chloric uh intake I talk
about that in the book there's it's just
super easy it's a calculator and then
you begin
to segment out how you are going to
ingest dietary protein I wouldn't go
above 50 grams per meal you know for
someone like you I'd probably hit 40 to
50 at that first meal for sure it's not
very much data for that middle meal and
then potentially that last meal but
probably closer again 40 to 50 40 40 to
50 grams of protein in the food
is a massive amount like it's a very
very large amount of meat that's it's
like two two scoops of whey protein oh
that's true if you were looking to do it
through supplements but if you're
looking to do it let's say that we're
having it through salmon or we're having
it through uh eggs I mean how many EG
what's an egg eight six eggs that would
be six yeah six eggs would be about 30
grams when you six six eggs is no joke
okay hang on hang on you brush past this
forcing 50 grams of protein six eggs so
it's five five grams per egg is yeah
right okay so you're you're talking
about 10 eggs 10 eggs is a lot of eggs
you better get started I I it's so it
seems but this is my point right you
look at this plate and I think even for
me now I see it now in myself I'm like
God every single I think you did an
Instagram you did an Instagram post
about this right you hit your protein
you hit your protein goals for the day
and then you realize God I've got to do
it all over again tomorrow embarrassing
I have a an amazing aming team that
makes me uh they tell me I'm more
relatable if I look like an ass so yeah
how's that goinging oh it's so terrible
um but yes this is you are not alone in
that now I'm gonna challenge you Austin
so we live in Houston I have been down
to Austin and they have a lot of
restaurants I can't even believe I mean
they have a lot of restaurants you go
and you order at one of those
restaurants a like filet and this my
friend is your 8 ounce filet that true
or not true eight times seven I mean
you're getting almost 60 grams of
protein in that tiny little fillet that
you spent $75 on so it can be
done fair enough I should I should go
for filet more on first thing in the
morning okay so we are making sure that
we measure because that's the only way
that we can manage this stuff we are
prioritizing protein within a 24-hour
window we're aiming for 0.7 grams per
pound of body weight or ideal body
weight we're also then considering that
there is a little bit of protein timing
going on here in that much more than
about 40 to 50 grams of protein in any
one meal is probably going to be a
little bit wasted presumably from an
efficiency perspective but just I'm I'm
pretty sure Stan taught me under 20
grams under 20 to 15 20 to 15 grams it
can actually be metabolized in a
different way so it's like The Sweet
Spot appears to be more than 20 less
than 50 something like that yeah I would
say that that that is right when you're
getting below 20 again you're you're not
you're not hitting that Lucine threshold
and Lucine is one of the essential amino
acids it's that Branch chain amino acid
and um my mentor of 20 years was the guy
who put the science behind a lot of the
um literature that we stand on today
this idea of protein dosing this idea of
a meal threshold this was some of his
work that he put out into the world
which is incredible to see this innov
before they knew that Lucine somehow
stimulated muscle but he really
connected the dots and then translated
it over to humans um and this idea that
something below a lucing threshold so
the average loosing threshold for an
adult is two and a half grams by the way
the RDA for for Lucine and we'll talk
about this in another podcast is uh
between two and three for the whole day
but the
actual are the actual uh influence and
more optimal amount is two to three
grams of Lucine per
meal yeah there's a there's an imbalance
here between what is being recommended
and what is optimal I mean the Aging
population is the fastest growing
population I was just looking at data
earlier um but so the idea of the 20
grams or less is it it will get counted
towards calories but it's not going to
do anything for muscle in that way okay
so just to round out the timing thing
which I think some people will be
considering because everyone likes to
obsess over stuff that doesn't really
matter is the big hammer mover of this
not less than 20 not more than 50 spread
it out over you know no one's eating
less than like 100 grams no matter how
slight you are therefore you need at
least three meals a day are you bothered
at all about a post exercise window no
no
no there uh I think that is it
beneficial I would say that the
literature would say no it's as long as
you're eating that protein does it have
to be right after you train it doesn't I
will say could there possibly be some
benefit eating after you if you are
untrained and you train and then you are
older and you are prioritizing
protein would your body be primed for a
bit more efficiency quite possibly could
I get a lot of push back on the
scientists from the scientists in that
yes it's something that I was having a
conversation about this morning and from
the literature they would say there's
really not great data that the post
exercise window is helpful my argument
would be well there's probably a place
for it there's probably it just seems
like there's bigger there's bigger fish
to fry here totally totally the the yeah
yes you have to protect body composition
at all costs we have to stop focusing on
what we have to lose and we really have
to hone in on what we have to gain what
are we mentioned earlier on that uh your
body is the average of the five most
common meales that you cook um what
never never heard that well I just made
it up that's why why what are your most
eaten meal preps like what what has most
of your body been built on over the last
few decades do you
think uh eggs frittata turkey
beef Dairy I'm actually a lower fat
person um and then I I don't agree with
high fat either my body really doesn't
like it yeah I I don't do well on that
and then adding in a lot of antoin so
MIA Berry which is that really rich
purple color um and I just try to add in
um whether it's blue algae I mean I try
to add in really colorful things why
because I think that there are
biochemical properties in them that
again we just there's so many we just
haven't gotten to it cool okay what
about superfoods if you were to rank
order you want to get the best yeah uh
protein profile you want to get the best
nutritional profile whilst getting
protein in what's your top five well
before I answer this do I have to
actually eat it
um no but if it tastes if it tastes
disgusting then it doesn't count so yeah
maybe but not for you for personal
personal taste um liver is disgusting
but it is so high in nutrition um women
that are anemic individuals that need
Vitamin A fat soluble vitamins liver is
amazing amazing Iron Source o two ounces
a day I mean I whatever you can stomach
without throwing up holding your nose
eating it however you have to do it uh I
think it's valuable I
I've got I've got a hack for it I've got
a hack for it salt the living [__] out
of it when it's frozen throw it in an
air fryer for two minutes either side
and it doesn't really taste like liver
anymore it probably doesn't it probably
tastes like cardboard two
minutes either side you crazy you're
crazy you're you're crazy lady okay okay
so liver first but you've got an issue
with that you're bigoted bigoted against
liver okay so what second um a lean beef
lean beef is amazing again why because
it has creatine anene
torine iron zinc selenium these are all
bioavailable uh vitamins and minerals
really important so that would be my
next one what cuts would you be looking
at I don't actually care so I get really
lean Cuts I I get it from buff cow have
you ever seen a a ped Monte's cow yeah
I'm with I'm with I'm sponsored by ped
Mones yeah they're great they don't
sponsor me come on guys I'll intro you
I'll intro you to the guys got an entire
freezer filled with ped Mones in there I
literally had some uh filet before I
came in but only but how many ounces uh
28 fair fair so um a lean beef is
amazing the next thing that I would say
with the next superfood from a
bioavailable source of protein could be
eggs eggs is great and whey protein also
great but again A Way concentrate H
again chicken I don't eat a bunch of
chicken salmon is good for omega-3 fatty
acids but it is a little on that the
fattier side and over time you do have
to worry about Mercury we test that in
my clinic uh you do have to worry about
some heavy metals and and tuna those
kinds of things one of the things that
always feels like a a rate limiting step
on salmon for me is I I really struggle
to make good salmon at home like it's
kind of it's just not you know throw a
steak in the air fryer it comes out you
get it wrong by 5 minutes either side
it's still edible you you throw salmon
in a frying pan and care for it like a
small baby chick and it just ends up it
ends up atomizing itself all over the
kitchen it's it's very easy to get wrong
and um that just limits how much I can
eat salmon at home I like it when I go
out for food but I think it's it's like
rough to to try and make good at home I
would agree I I would totally agree so
basically we've covered liver hold your
nose and eat it lean beef ped monties
choose a buff cow um eggs whey and
salmon so I hit my five mhmh that's good
that's good work okay fair enough talk
to me about the relationship of sleep
and muscle building of what we've going
on here yeah there's um I actually just
interviewed Dr Emily Lance on my podcast
and she is out of the Galveston group
she's scientist out of the Galviston
group and one of the the studies that
she worked on was that uh was looking at
sleep and muscle protein
synthesis sleep one night of sleep
deprivation can suppress muscle protein
synthesis by
18%
can you imagine cumulative over time
that's not good that's my life that's me
that's that's being a club promoter for
a decade and a half yeah yes and I will
say one of the other things that we see
so muscle protein
synthesis on one hand is suppressed but
there is some data coming out that if
you are sleep
deprived then kicking up training so
like the military personnel they go
through four days or five days of hell
week I should know this because I've
never heard the end of winter hell week
it's just you know right exactly like
that's hard um but there is some
evidence to support that training during
that time during a time of sleep
deprivation can help support the tissue
which makes perfect sense it can
mitigate some of the effects from lack
of
sleep so we hear about you know
Downstream some of the concerns that
people have around uh you are more
likely to like uh salty foods uh more
likely to reach for highly processed
foods more irritable lower willpower all
the rest of that stuff but what you're
talking about here is a much more direct
mechanism from even if you go full bed
Ross culing and and Wrangle your
willpower and you don't eat the cookie
and you do the thing you are still
creating a glass ceiling on your ability
to build muscle just based on how much
time you had to sleep and I no amount of
breath work or meditation or like
ratchet hip hop is going to be able to
get you past that so yeah I think I mean
it's just it's just
another another reminder that everybody
is probably forgetting and again I we're
getting tactical on this one I quite
like the fact that we're doing this you
need to try a sleep tracker whether it's
an eight Sleep mattress whether it's a
whoop whether it's an aura ring
obviously if you use whoop that would be
great because I think that they're an
awesome partner but the main thing that
you learn when you use a sleep tracker
is you are not sleeping anywhere near as
much as you think you are MH like that's
I I can save you from having to buy one
right it's great if you do it and it's
important to learn this lesson firsthand
but the lesson that you learn as soon as
you start using a fitness tracker is Oh
I thought I was getting eight hours of
sleep but it turns out I was actually in
bed for 7 hours 45 and my active sleep
was 6 hours
20 oh [__] like that's that's the
realization that's what you spend most
of your time time and now for me even if
I don't have this on I know I'm like
look if I need 8 hours sleep I got to be
in bed for 9 hours like I have to even
if I try and cranked my sleep efficiency
as best as possible bit of latency bit
of lost sleep efficiency some micro
Awakenings throughout the night it's
like guess what it's hard to hit and by
the way and no offense to The Sleep
ninjas out there sleep is annoying
there's a lot of other things that I
would rather be doing than sleeping
sleep it is right but I will tell you
that in when I was a fellow and we were
in the memory and aging Clinic one of
the risk factors for Alzheimer's was we
always asked about sleep deprivation
over time because when you sleep this is
when the brain cleans itself these gal
cells that and actually sleeping with a
phone by your head yeah I mean anyone no
one in my audience still has their phone
in their bedroom Gabrielle no one not
not one I know no one at all or else
they are no longer allowed to listen
okay so when we're looking at this sort
of relationship sleep to uh muscle
building is there anything else I want
to get on training but before we get
into that we've talked about diet we've
talked about recovery is there anything
else we're missing in kind of the milu
that is life beyond now training
stimulus I think the big picture is
eating Whole Foods it doesn't have to be
complicated it should be high protein
from my perspective there's no reason
that when you have the luxury to eat
that way you don't it is a luxury and a
privilege to be able to prioritize
dietary protein other countries don't
get that and it is a highly
nutrient-dense source of um calories and
a non-negotiable especially as
individual's age you know when you had
mentioned that when you were really into
fasting and and you were reducing food
intake that that um it just it may not
be an ideal mechanism right just fluffy
I was Fluffy we don't want too fluffy it
would just ruin your image so I'm not
supposed to be fluffy I'm [__] 19 and
a half% body fat compared according to
that dexa scan in Dallas that should
ruin your day for at least a week really
did I think I I think I need to I think
I need to go on a slight cut here's a
point here's a question I've had in my
head actually there is somebody that's
listening who is both overfat and
underused right yeah there is someone
who just doesn't have the body
composition that they want and they know
that they are off on both ends of the
scale
M if it was me not knowing your world
what I would do for me is I would
probably diet myself down because I'm
going to get the Aesthetics way quicker
by becoming Lena first which I can crack
out in the space of six months and then
building my muscle up from there but
what would you do what what would your
advice be would you just try and recm
through everything like how how do you
go about this CU motivation is going to
be gauged as much by the mirror as it is
probably by anything else so we need to
satiate that in people yeah if it were
me I would focus on what I have to gain
versus what I have to lose if I had very
little muscle and a lot of body fat then
from my perspective I would not actually
be focused on anything aesthetic I would
assume that I was not as strong as I
should be and not as physically capable
as I needed to be I would focus
primarily on being a human that was
physically strong and I'm not
necessarily training for strength but
maybe you would train for some strength
and some hypertrophy but I would just
start putting in the Reps I would start
putting in the Reps I would obviously
see what my Baseline diet is prioritized
dietary protein is very difficult to
store protein as fat it's very difficult
like you said you're like ah I got to 90
grams if I have one more buffed cow I'm
gonna shoot myself it becomes very
difficult to overeat dietary protein and
there may be some impact on this
adaptive thermogenesis you know the
body's very smart so if you start
reducing calories to rapidly the body
will adjust but dietary protein and from
my perspective one of the reasons why it
has this more thermic effect of food
thermic effect of feeding is that um
it's so valuable and it does stimulate
muscle protein synthesis that that the
Machinery of that may take more energy
than the energy required to utilize
carbohydrates could be 10% fats could be
5% and and protein could be anywhere
between 15 and 20% again depend on the
study that you look at um and foods are
not just primarily one
thing if you are an individual who needs
to lose weight and build muscle could
you do both at the same time you could
would it be as effective no I would say
you start with what you have to lose
because that indivi what you have to
gain because that individual didn't get
there by focusing on what they had to
gain I guarantee you they have spent a
lifetime yo-yo dieting or having some uh
feeling of just you know it doesn't feel
good in your body if you're not feeling
well right I I think that we can all
agree on that potentially again I don't
know but if this is for me this is what
I would do I I I think that I like your
framing
around uh people are told that there is
something that they have to lose it's
all about getting rid getting rid
getting that out of this body and it
really is a it's like an anti-b building
mentality within your physiology and I
don't think that that is particularly
constructive Okay so we've danced around
it right we've got all of the things in
place but we actually need to go out
there and build some muscle now we need
some we need some training stimulus if
you only had 10 exercises for the rest
of time to build and maintain as much
muscle as you could what would they be
in
why 10 10 that's it that's it it seems
like a
I would definitely do a squat right I
would do a back squat I would a lower uh
a lower lower on my back a wider stance
just because um yes so I would
definitely do a squat why why why low
why low bar why wi squat just my
physiology just the way I'm built okay
okay the way I'm built so I actually
decided side note that it was a great
idea to do a 50-hour event uh that was
Non-Stop and so as I was training for
that I torn my hamstring off the I
evoled it around 80 some perc off the
bone just a really uh wasn't my smartest
decision yeah so it's it's been this
process of repair let's just say that so
I've had to modify some of my training
so a a squat a wider stance squat some
kind of deadlift whether it's a Sumo
deadlift or some kind of deadlift
because just the mechanics and also the
full body uh movement of a squat I would
also say a farmer carry we have to also
begin to choose and this is what I think
about this is I think about all the
older patients that I've seen being able
to carry groceries being able to carry a
toddler being able to you know it's it's
amazing when we think about traveling
you know I I I travel a lot I also have
two very little kids I have a
two-year-old and a four-year-old um if
you want some birth control I will send
them right over to your right over to
your house and you'll you'll see you
know be careful you'll hear people say
oh be careful about putting this
overhead you you know the weight limit
shouldn't exceed this and it's just a
whole backwards way of thinking about it
no no no you are afraid to then go into
the gym and lift a 50 pound uh weight
but you will have no trouble lifting
your or struggling to lift your 50 PB
toddler to to put them XY wherever
you're putting them why given the fact
that you've already got a good bit of
midline activation with your Squat and
especially with your deadlift plus
you've got grip work with your deadlift
what are you getting out of the
farmers's carry that you haven't
activated already well you're getting
motion and you're getting something that
translates to real life it's you know
when we are if we're really talking
about health span we have to talk about
the things that will destroy Health span
and the reasons why we require help why
do we go into a nursing home what are
the things that really affect quality of
life the number one thing that affects
quality of life is physical mobility in
my opinion and I've seen this so not
being able to can you imagine not being
able to climb upstairs not being able to
carry your groceries not being able to
put them up I mean I was just traveling
here to Las Vegas and there was a couple
in front of me that couldn't put their
uh luggage on their carry-ons on the con
had oh no on the conveyor Bel [__]
conveyor belt oh okay and you know what
I was like do I help them do I help them
but if I help them they're never gonna
get
exercise so you watched this person
struggle with a one rep max hand luggage
carry but I I I know was ter I really
struggle why but no because if that is
the one moment they're going to be able
to pick something up and move in a
rotational way to put it there which is
how we move we're not homeboy granddad's
got Doms for the next two weeks because
you didn't help him move his 15 pound
suitcase okay three we've got a squat
barbell back squat low moment arm wide
stance uh a deadlift and a farmer carry
what's next so the exercise I think that
um this is not necessarily A
weightlifting exercise so we didn't uh
specify but doing some kind of an
interval on a an assault bike or an
airdine being able to push out above a
90% V2 Max just really hitting it you
prove to yourself you can do it it feels
awful but it is a way to improve insulin
sensitivity it's extremely effective and
I I I really do think that as we are
training in the gym it's not just about
the machines it's not just about the
bands but it's about being fit and
capable for real life it's true God
forbid there is an emergency you better
be able to show up and be a capable
human well this is the uh this is you
know I think Petra's biggest Flex from a
training perspective at the moment or
his kind of biggest Obsession when I
spoke to him early this year and he's
saying you know VO2 max is one of the
best predictors that we have of
someone's longevity and I was like what
like what I thought it was all Zone 2 I
thought it was all to do with resting
heart rate and variability and blood
oxygenation and and and galvanic skin
respon
he like just straight up V2 Max what's
your V2 Max so that that was surprising
to me to hear that and I do think that
we are I think that there is um somewhat
of a discrepancy in the literature when
it comes to muscle mass and strength
right now people will say strength
matters in muscle mass it's not about
the actual mass it's really about the
strength I think that we are at the
precipice of literature changing as we
begin to directly measure skeletal
muscle mass through some of these you
know more Advan Advanced ways like this
D3 creatine and I think that that May
challenge right now if V2 Max is is the
greatest predictor I think we're also
going to see um a change in the
literature when it comes to muscle size
and strength I think that is going to be
next and I I yeah so I'll say that just
that it's interesting
how there are theories about the way the
way that the human body works but we
don't have the measuring tools to be
able to make it happen yet so what we do
is we find proxies for that strength is
a pretty good proxy for muscle mass
there's very few people that are very
strong without being at least a little
bit muscled but what's the genuine
mechanism that's going on here is it
that the only thing that we can measure
accurately is hand grip or bench press
or vertical jump or whatever I I
actually just had a conversation with I
work with a um a PhD her name is Alexis
Cowen she did her PhD at Princeton she's
now at pen she's really helped with the
Institute of Muscle Centric medicine and
we were going back and forth about grip
strength I think that again this is
another you know Chris my perspective is
just because something is spoken about
over and over and over again doesn't
make it true it doesn't mean that we're
looking at it from the right perspective
and yes we could say grip strength is a
biomarker but if we take a step back we
have to ask ourselves um are we
potentially born with a certain
threshold for grip strength is it really
the end all Beall are are we sure that
that's true and the next layer to that
just goes in line with when we're
talking about skeletal muscle so right
now we're talking about V2 Max but again
that's because perhaps we've had the
tools to measure it and then bringing to
the conversation which is often missed
is that we don't highlight the things
that we're doing well um I'm sorry we
highlight the things that we are
potentially doing well without the
Insight of potentially the things that
were're not and the oversights in um
just measuring
indices what is your favorite
evidence-based protocol on an airine or
an assault bike for improving V2
Max um great question I actually work
with a trainer I don't do any of the
protocols myself what does he make you
do Carlos Carlos is a major [__] [__]
you Carlos oh oh man the worst I mean so
Friday right before I left we just did
um max effort it was it was 20 seconds
allout effort trying to push me above or
to 90 um 90% And then he would give me
10c rest so I don't know if that's I
felt like okay so like a tobata style
thing but holding it for like doing it
in 30 second intervals how many rounds
do you do he only had me do three
minutes thank God yeah that's still
that's six rounds right that's that's
that's enough to kill you okay cool uh
so you've got only four things what
anything else bed no no let's keep going
so U we said a squat we said a deadlift
Sumo deadlift for me we said a a carry y
um I definitely think that you should be
able to do an overhead carry I think
that you should be strong in an overhead
position even though obviously it's
probably not totally stable for the
reason that I just like I'd like to see
you be able to do that over time um I
also think being able to do things like
push-ups getting off the floor you have
to be able to do push-ups have to be
able to develop that upper body strength
um Also let's see what else what else do
I think is a
non-negotiable I mean I think a Turkish
getup is great takes coordination it
takes capacity you have to get balance
uh and then gunar Peterson would say
Gabrielle you have to add in something
rotational so any rotational whether
it's a swing or a uh something
rotational he said being able to throw
punches at a at a bag something like
that yeah I mean the the FL it's
interesting that you've brought up two
things that get you down to the ground
uh with the push-up and then
specifically Turkish Get Up which I was
thinking about earlier on Aaron
Alexander from the Align podcast has he
is one of these huge proponents of
sitting desks right so a floor desk and
I have in the other house through there
I have this tiny little what look I
think it's meant for Japanese
calligraphy so I think it's meant for
when you're sat doing your
fancy Japanese like penmanship or
something uh and I've got varying
Heights of meditation cushion behind it
uh and his whole thing is get yourself
down on the ground spend an hour half an
hour to an hour a day with your hips
below your knees if you can and I have
to say sitting down there feels so nice
like glut me opens all of that out when
I get into that kind of cross-legged
position uh and you can lift your hips
up and actually Lean Forward which feels
really lovely on your lower back that
feels like it kind of decompresses a
little bit like it's so nice like all of
that's really really good so I am in I'm
down for ground stuff yeah um that I
that sounds very interesting I cannot
wait to see that and uh it's never going
to be made public I mean remaining it's
remaining private that's if I went full
Austin psychedelic bro mode I wouldn't
be at a standing desk I would be on the
floor
and I would be I would be like twirling
a a what is it like a [__] iasa stick
between my fingers while I'm doing it
okay so let's say that you've got three
more three more things that you can
introduce um I do think again so we we
talked about how we would use uh grip
strength so you know you're developing
grip strength you're developing you
being able to carry I don't know if we
talked about a swing but I do think that
you should be able to swing you should
be able to do some kind of dynamic
movements I think that that is important
and again how do you translate these
things to real life a Turkish getup so
we have squat uh Sumo deadlift we have a
throw up on the devil's tricycle we have
um some kind of push-up right pushing up
after off the ground we have um kettle
ball swing farmer carry farmer
carry what else I know see you gave me
10 and then you know you might Phil
Heath wanted Phil Heath wanted 11 and
Bumstead also like rolled his eyes at me
only him 10 so you you've got bags of
spare capacity you only needed eight I
mean I think also you should where are
we going to get like where are we going
to get jacked arms from here I I I was
actually thinking that but you said but
your your question was that you could
only do for the rest of time to build
and maintain as much muscle as you could
what would they be maybe may I would be
tempted to maybe throw in some sort of
pullup like we haven't got we haven't
got much of that scapular attraction I
guess in the dead that's a lie the
deadlift we have
okay fair fair C phases if Alex hosi was
here he would say Cal phrases because he
calls he keeps on texting me and telling
me that Cals are the front garden of the
of the body I'm like at best they're the
backyard right at best they're the
backyard they're not even on the front
of your body you can't make this wait by
the way women don't care about calves
he would
say that's because you haven't seen my
cves that's what he would say I know
that he would he would
say what about what about these cves and
I would say that's your backyard but
okay yeah cool I think what's what's
really interesting I'm loving asking
this question to pretty much all of the
health and fitness people that I speak
to it's really indicative of where
they're coming from from a health and
fitness perspective you know it's
obvious that you've got that like sort
of geriatric care background because
you're thinking training for life life
right like no one else has said oh yeah
I'd love to put a farmer's carry in
because like so what like I just presume
that my my deadlift or like my row or
something is going to be able to get me
through the carrying side but the you
know that contralateral moving thing
that being able to stabilize the trunk
while the hips move underneath you I
think that's really important so yeah
we've ended up I think we've got like
maybe a library of 80 exercises now
you're the first person in all of them
that hasn't said uh dumbbell side
lateral raises but um that's hilarious
that's okay uh but I will say my
perspective comes from you know I talk
about I did my training as a
geriatrician but my patient population
we take care of elite War Fighters my
patient population is we service Elite
Warf Fighters and like CEO Maverick guys
that are just super physically fit and
they I would say I mean I don't know
what all of them are doing but I would
say the major majority of them have a
lot of well-rounded training
programs right and my perspective is as
a mom I have two little
children can you imagine if I went down
to pick one up and one's pissing on the
wall and the other one's doing something
else I had to grab the other one I have
to be able to move fast enough so my new
drapes don't get ruined that's obviously
the priority when it comes to uh Tempo
rep ranges set ranges what are people
getting wrong in your opinion I think
think there now first of all there is a
phenomenal paper and that I think that
anyone who's really interested in these
uh this repetition Continuum the paper
is called loading recommendations for
muscle strength hypertrophy hopefully
I'll get it right local endurance a
reexamination of the Continuum
repetition or the repetition Continuum
very very sexy title for a paper please
translate amazing and really basically
um it it highlights that we've got this
strength hypertrophy endurance that
we've really put things into buckets and
that maybe the evidence doesn't support
that that there's multiple ways to get
stimulus so what do I think that people
are getting wrong potentially that you
know if you're just going eight to 12
reps maybe that's just hypertrophy but
for older
individuals they potentially could do
lighter weights and go for longer and
still get hypertrophy uh influence so I
think that this rep range
Continuum uh could be
reexamined what about what what's what's
your thoughts on uh tot time and
detention um all valuable Tempo stuff
all valuable and all ways to change up
your training program because what
you're looking for is really a
physiological adaptation right and
there's multiple ways to get that
multiple ways to improve muscle
hypertrophy and strength and endurance
so what you're looking for is where your
stimulus is and where you need to
potentially push on the lever to improve
in my mind again as a physician you do
have to track improvements it's not just
that you're tracking your uh whatever
you're eating your beef or Twinkies or
Etc you also do have to track weights
the same way now I think a baseline
recommendation you know in my book I I
want people to know how many push-ups
they can do this morning I did 600
push-ups here in Vegas working out with
Ben Newman it's a terrible idea why 600
why stupid number I I way too many I
said this and obviously it wasn't all at
once but I was just thinking myself man
what an idiot idea that is you should
have done less you should have said have
we have you thought about doing fewer
yeah exactly and by the way they all did
probably more than I did um but again so
that's the number one thing I think
people are getting wrong is that it's
either and I used to say you know my own
personal belief is that you have to work
really hard and that's just a belief
that's not necessarily in the evidence I
think that there's something to be said
there is evidence to support this idea
that the um the influence of what you
are doing whether you are lifting light
whether you are lifting heavy that the
molecular influence is somewhat
different right and that that makes
sense but my belief had always been that
you should train harder and that was the
only way to do it and that is not
necessarily what the evidence
supports which is disappointing but for
for the people that want to punish
themselves with 600 press-ups on a
morning in Vegas no it is I can see why
that would be a like a personal insult
uh when it comes to people tracking
their sets and tracking their workouts
there is an app called heavy set which
is by far the most seamless and least
intrusive
of the workout tracking things that I've
ever found it's phenomenal it links up I
don't have one but it links up with your
Apple watch it can track tonnage it can
track progression it can you can work in
super sets and drop sets and rest Paws
and myor Reps and all sorts of other
craziness and it'll tell you what your
proposed one rep max is based on all of
the calculations it's really good and I
think it might even be free if you don't
need to use anything fancy so that's
heavy set it's definitely available for
iOS it might be available for Android as
well what else what else what given this
global perspective
of stop focusing on fat stop focusing on
muscle these are the principles from a
dietary perspective these are the
principles from a a training stimulus
perspective sleep is important is there
anything else that we're missing from
this Paradigm I I want to point
something out because it's important for
the
conversation we've talked about skeletal
muscle we've talked about nutrition
influence in skeletal muscle we've
talked about the history we've talked
about
exercise I would say that a lot of
people will recognize these things as
important Contracting skeletal muscle
releases
myokines myokines are hormones they are
molecules that are released from
Contracting skeletal muscle there's 600
or more it it the first myoc kind I
think was discovered in 2000 by
Patterson in Copenhagen so this is not
that old and I just want to reframe the
conversation into what does it mean from
a muscle Centric medicine perspective a
medicine perspective Contracting
skeletal muscle we've all heard about
these cyto kindes cyto kindes like
interlan 6 interlan 15 and the cyto kind
storm and you know it had its moment
exercising skeletal muscle the degree at
which you are exercising will influence
the amount of inter Lucan 6 and Inter
Lucan 15 that when released from
skeleton muscle interfaces with the body
differently than those inter lucans that
are released from
macras so there is a a blunting effect
from an inflammation standpoint which I
think is important to point out also why
is that important because it's
leveraging skeletal muscle tissue that
you
have conscious control over to augment
your immune system and to augment your
inflammatory response
so it's a um something that you can do
consciously that is going to tap into a
system which is largely run on autopilot
yes yes and Contracting skeletal muscle
releases glutamine glutamine is a
semi-essential amino acid that you know
the requirements depending on if you're
under stress or a highly catabol State
Etc but Contracting skeletal muscle when
it is when it releases glutamine
glutamine serves as a fuel source for
lymphocytes white blood blood cells so
doing an action consciously I mean you
can't tell your heart I don't know you
live in Austin there might be people
that could tell their heart to pump at a
certain rate but for the most part
unless you're whim Hof you're probably
going to have a difficult time telling
an organ system to do just the thing
it's the only thing that you have that
kind of control over so this influence
of Contracting skeletal muscle we talked
about Alzheimer's it releases bdnf and
irisin and capsacin
which stimulate bdnf release in the
brain which help with neurogenesis with
brain
function this is critical in changing
the conversation of muscle as it is
thought of in this way of looking good
naked and and uh a training all
important and the only things that we
have actionable control over but also
reframing the conversation from an
immune perspective from um a perspective
as an endocrine organ really really
critical very
interesting yeah I um I'm going to be
I'm going to be watching carefully I
guess over the next few years to see if
the the pivot does happen it seems like
Diet culture which is what it is
currently right it's diet culture is
very ingrained it's the dominant
ideology for improving Fitness and
improving health and I suppose you know
if you were to take somebody that is
however many 00 and get them to lose 30%
of their body mass like that a lot of
their outcomes are massively going to
improve but I would guess that for a lot
of the people that are listening to this
podcast they're actually thinking okay
like I I understand that that's
important and you know in like a
charitable aspect I want to remind
people Whole Foods and do all the rest
of it it's like okay like what's the
what's the next step what's getting
yourself maybe from 50 to 70 or from 90
to
95 yeah I wonder I wonder how much of
this muscle centered medicine is going
to be something important I mean like I
say the benefits are massive because
it's one of the few things that you can
do that is hard that is immediately
gratifying of in the shorts to
medium-term is gratifying and also has
long-term Health impacts and you can't
say that for many other training
modalities you know you get really great
at
rowing you don't look that different you
may feel great you know the metrics on
your whoop will say oh wow my resting
heart rate's in the 40s but really you
know if you train Push Pull legs for six
months and you
eat 7 grams per pound of body weight in
protein you look Worlds Apart if you're
someone who's even like up to a probably
pretty well done trainer right like if
you've been training for even a while
and you stick to that you're going to
look great so yeah you have the
opportunity to kind of come for the
gains and stay for the longevity I think
that
I think it's a an relatively easy cell I
I think it's an easy cell and I'll tell
you some of you know one of the the
aspects of being a physician is and I
say this all the time is that a good
physician recognizes patterns of
diseases right a good physici that is
your job that is your craft you need to
be able to recognize patterns of illness
an effective physician an effective
physician recognizes patterns of people
and that is how you move the needle we
can talk about all of this stuff but the
reality is there are certain archetypes
of individuals and one thing that I will
tell you is that individuals must feel
worthy of doing the thing that is going
to move the needle there is a self-worth
threshold that people have they will
only ever be as fit and lose as much
weight or gain as much muscle if they
start to feel too good or look too good
it's a whole Litany of do I deserve this
do I feel worthy of this can I really
have these things and I have been a
practicing physician for a very long
time and then the second layer to that
is understanding that you have to close
the gap you show me who you are today
and the habits you are doing today I can
tell you I can tell you a handful of
things number one I can tell you how
successful you are there is a spectrum
and an archetype of innovators and and
Mavericks and CEO archetypes I can tell
you based on your habits where you land
on that
Spectrum number two the actions that you
take now in your health and wellness
today I can tell you what you your life
will look like in the future your
present is your future especially from a
health
perspective an individual that moves the
the needle has to be aware of their
weaknesses we are in a culture where
where it's all about what are your
strengths and how are you doing and
you're so amazing I don't care anything
about that I need to know where you fail
where you fall off and you have to know
that because it's predictable every T
every single time for example every time
Chris I bet you if you did not mitigate
when you did those Live Events you
probably if you were not aware that at
the peak of that EV event there was
going to be a component of vulnerability
right after you would have fallen off
your nutrition plan you would have felt
a little depressed and you would have
stopped
training did that happen or did you
mitigate
that yeah we worked around it you worked
around it you planned for it you
probably went in with a more neutral
mindset thinking this might go well this
might not this is my first thing this is
so cool you neutralized it it wasn't
that big of a deal and again I'm putting
words in your mouth I don't know you
neutralized
it
you must be able to close the gap
between who you want to be your future
self and who you're the actual actions
that you are
taking because time is limited and if
you continue to do the same thing then
you have to fast forward and the pain of
failure over everything else is more
effective in moving a patient to
action you said in a a different
interview I heard you say if if you
think you don't have time for Fitness
how are you going to have time for
sickness and I think that's a that's a
good way to look at it we everybody is
busy everybody has a lot of things to do
everyone has more emails to answer than
time to complete the workout but yeah I
feel it Dr Gabrielle L ladies and
gentlemen where should people go they
want to keep up to date with your work
they want to check out the new book
where would you send them on the
Internet well you can go to my website
Dr Gabriel lion.com and you can find all
our offerings there uh I also have a
podcast the Dr Gabrielle lion show which
I've been trying to get you on Chris for
I don't know at least like six months
I'm going to convince you I'll say I'll
bring you like some frittatas whatever
um you can also get my book on Amazon
it's called Forever Strong depending on
when this comes out and I have a great
newsletter I put out a ton of free
content YouTube and I have a full
practice we have a team so people can
check out my website hell yeah gabri I
appreciate you thank you thank you if
you enjoyed that episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
subscribe